jetzt sind dafür erst einmal einen
oberstleutnant seinen soldaten hein
donner
wenn man die einführung geht kommt
wohnzimmer ist und weil es offiziell
und weil es zu den karten gang kleinmann
schlussmann angelernt werden eigentlich
die jäger komponieren untersteht
und da nur wo es dass der patch
eigentlich an der seite der mann bei
sowie sekt was bedeutet exemplar dozent
und zwar führen durch beispiel noch
einmal nur ein vortrag von
sozialreferenten noch einmal gefragt da
sind unsere arbeitgeber versichert hat
und mir hat das bundesamt noch einmal
nur an exellence corp und da haben aber
neue sachen kennenlernt nachgingen
der linke fuß herbeigezogen
die hände bilder faust und liegen am ohr
schenkt klaren okay wenn es dann wieder
zurück gängen in die rückstellung wird
der linke fuß wieder höchst
bereitgestellt und die hinten
gleichzeitig immer auch begreift ein
stolzer blick
[Musik]